people of the internet retrorecontour
here do you think i am wearing the
correct shirt is this the appropriate
house for me we're about to find out in
today's video i know one of the things
people can't wait for in hogwarts legacy
is the sorting ceremony we don't really
know how it's going to work yet will
there be some sort of quiz or will we
just choose that's kind of what the faq
makes it sound like it sounds like we're
just going to pick the house that we
want now i'm sure many of you out there
have already done the pottermore quiz
but there are actually websites out
there that have the entire list of
pottermore questions which i think gives
you an even better representation of
your true house now many of you in the
comments have asked me my house before
and i've always said gryffindor i will
tell you though there was one time
one time that i took a quiz and did not
get gryffindor and dumbledore even said
he thinks that they sort too early so i
haven't taken one of these things in
years guys so this is going to be really
interesting to see and i want you to be
along for the ride as well i'll be sure
and link this quiz down in the
description below so you can participate
if you want let me know which house you
get in the comments
here we go okay so there are 29
total questions and as i said in the
opening guys i haven't taken one of
these things in a long time so it'll be
really interesting to see
if my
tendencies have changed i don't know so
here we go number one here which of the
following would you most hate people to
call you
ordinary ignorant
cowardly or selfish so
none of these are particularly great if
somebody calls me ordinary that's not
going to bother me too much
ignorant
i don't really like being called
ignorant but if you really think about
what ignorance really is it just means
that you're unaware of something you're
uninformed about something so if you're
ignorant about something i feel like
that's not that huge of an insult even
though sometimes it can sound like it
it's like okay well i may be ignorant
about it now but i can change that
but man cowardly cowardly is kind of in
the lead i really would not want anyone
to call me
cowardly fight back you can't fight back
when people call me selfish i think
sometimes that really helps me to kind
of look inward and see wow maybe i
actually was being selfish about this
honestly though like coward for me
that's that's the biggest insult number
two after you have died what would you
most like people to do when they hear
your name
miss you but smile
ask for more stories about your
adventures
think with admiration of you
achievements i think it means your
achievements i don't care what people
think of me after i'm dead it's what
they think of me while i'm alive that
counts well definitely not the last one
i have always been
very big on legacy i i want i want to
leave something behind whether it's a
book this youtube channel just the way
that i treat people around me that lives
on after i'm gone
miss you but smile
i mean that's
i don't know that one seems a little
boring for me it's gonna be one of these
two in the middle here ask for more
stories about your adventures obviously
retrorecontour i'm just a dad who loves
games and the stories they tell i'm very
big on stories and i do have quite a few
of adventures but then this number three
is pretty appealing too think with
admiration of your achievements
there's a part of me that says
achievements and then there's a part of
me that says adventures more stories
about your adventures honestly at this
point in my life i think i gotta go with
that one my son loves hearing stories
right now so for one day for him to ask
people about tell me about the
adventures dad went on
that would be awesome or if you ask me
you know tell me about the adventures
you went on so i'm gonna go with that
one
all right number three given the choice
would you rather invent a potion that
would guarantee you glory wisdom
love
and power okay this one is a very easy
one for me
right away wisdom and i know which house
that's going toward i don't care i'm not
i'm not trying not to think about that
the reason i say wisdom is because for
someone who i think is truly
wise and and that's that's the key is
like how do you really define wisdom i
think for someone that is truly wise
they'll really be able to find all these
other things in life and if they don't
find these other things then they'll
they'll be more accepting of it right so
maybe they won't achieve glory but
because of the wisdom they have they'll
be okay with that
love i already have love if i didn't
have love then that one would be
really really close because it's asking
if you would rather invent a potion i
think i would rather find love naturally
power i'm really not interested at all
in power so i'm gonna go with wisdom
here
okay number four how would you like to
be known to history oh i like this retro
the wise retro the good
retro the bold retro the great
i mean all these sound pretty nice to me
right retrorecontour the wise retro
rackets were the good
i mean
again like it's so obvious which house
is which here
okay let's go through this one by one
i'm gonna go ahead and eliminate good
even though
i really do like that one i think people
could look at that and say you know good
and great of course i'd rather be great
but that really speaks to when when they
say good there i think they're talking
more about spreading good into the world
whereas great would be more like kind of
lifting yourself up
being propped on your achievements and i
already just answered one above saying
that i'd love to have wisdom so you know
i wouldn't hate it if somebody
remembered me as the wise but how would
i like to be known to history the bold
okay now these are the ones that i love
the most these situational questions
that like places you in an actual
example so number five here you enter an
enchanted garden what would you be most
curious to examine first
the silver leafed tree bearing golden
apples the fat red toadstools that
appear to be talking to each other
the bubbling pool in the depths of which
something luminous is swirling or the
statue of an old wizard with a strangely
twinkling eye which would i'd be most
curious to examine first okay so i'm
trying to pick here i walk into this
little
garden here and you just you see all
these things you've got the bubbling
pool you've got the silver leaf tree
you've got the statue you've got the fat
red toast stools
i mean my eyes are instantly going to be
drawn to toadstools that are talking
right i mean that is by far the most
interesting thing that you're going to
see there
but if i really want to go up and
examine i don't know if i would want to
go and examine them honestly deep water
like kind of freaks me out so looking
like down into a pool where i don't
really know what's under there
ah this one's tough this one's really
tough you know what i'm just gonna say
statue of the old wizard that's like
what my gut instinct says so i'm gonna
go with that one what kind of instrument
most pleases your ear violin drums piano
or trumpet again this one i know the
answer to
right away and i have no idea which one
relates to the war houses but for me it
is violin i have always always loved the
sound of the violin okay four boxes are
placed before you which would you try
and open
the small tortoise shell box embellished
with gold inside which some small
creatures seem to be squeaking that
one's instantly out no i don't want any
creatures squeaking
number two the gleaming jet black box of
with a silver lock and key marked with a
mysterious rune that you know to be the
mark of merlin okay that one's the lead
so far no doubt the ornate golden casket
standing on clawed feet whose
inscription warns that both secret
knowledge and unbearable temptation lie
within no i'm not opening a golden
casket standing on clawed feet no thank
you
and last the small pewter box unassuming
and plain with a scratched message upon
it that reads i open only for the worthy
oh that one's
that one's actually pretty tempting to
me i can't lie i open only for the
worthy because there's that mystery like
am i worthy but then there's the other
side of me that's like okay well if
you're not worthy what's happened are
you gonna be like cursed or something so
i'm gonna go gleaming jetbox with merlin
four goblets are placed before you which
would you choose to drink the foaming
frothing silvery liquid that sparkles as
though containing ground diamonds
the smooth thick richly purple drink
that gives off a delicious smell of
chocolate and plums not that one
the golden liquid so bright that it
hurts the eye and which makes sunspots
dance all around the room
probably that one so far or the last one
the mysterious black liquid that gleams
like ink and gives off fumes that make
you see strange visions
nah i'm staying away from that
foaming frothing i don't really like
foaming and frothing so i guess i gotta
go with the golden liquid here okay
moving on to number nine once every
century the flutterby bush produces
flowers that adapt their scent to
attract the unwary if it lured you it
would smell of
a crackling log fire
fresh parchment home or the sea
oh man this is this one's really tough
because home right like home is one of
those weird things because you don't
know what your own house smells like
until you go away for a while you're
visiting somebody and then you come back
and even then you only can smell it for
just like a second it's kind of like
what's that and it's gone the sea
i i don't love the smell of the seed to
be honest and then fresh parchment yeah
i'm gonna go with a crackling log fire
oh i do i definitely remember this
question a troll has gone berserk in the
headmaster study at hogwarts it is about
to smash crush and tear several
irreplaceable items and treasures
including a cure for dragon pox wow this
is a long sentence which the headmaster
has nearly perfected student records
going back a thousand years and a
mysterious handwritten book full of
strange runes believed to have belonged
to merlin in which order would you
rescue these objects from the trolls
club
if you could okay i'm just going to say
right off the bat here student records
a magic school should have some form of
backup other than actually written down
i don't know maybe in a pensive
somewhere you can't tell me that the
written records are the only ones so
immediately for me
that one is is going last and it looks
like some of these questions have have
left off the last one here because wait
in which order would you rescue these
okay they just shortened down records i
see what happened here so i think number
one has got to be the dragon pox cure
of course you you really do not want to
lose that cure number two i would say
merlin's book because you know very
powerful wizard there could be some
incredibly
valuable things in there that could also
lead to more cures and then last for me
is certainly going to be the student
record so for me that uh number one is
actually what i'm gonna go with there 11
which would you rather be now see i love
the questions like this that are more
than four options because it doesn't
just fit so neatly into gryffindor
ravenclaw hufflepuff slytherin trusted
liked imitated praised envied or feared
okay another typo here so maybe this
isn't the best quiz hopefully it's
actually accurate though uh i do like
people to think of me as trusted i do
like to be liked imitated
that's an interesting one
i don't really i don't care if people
imitate me or not praise i am i really
don't even care for praise all that much
envy
might surprise you envy is a little bit
appealing to me like i i don't know i
feel like that's a little slytherin
there feared i i really don't care or
want to be feared
so i think it's going to come down to
trusted liked or envied man do i want
people to envy me
i i mean there's there's part of me that
says yes but then envy is such like a
negative thing like that would mean
there almost
implies some jealousy there and i really
don't want that at all so i guess it
would come down to trusted or liked
you know what i'm gonna go with trusted
okay number 12 here which of the
following do you find most difficult to
deal with hunger
cold loneliness boredom or being ignored
dude i am cold all the time and
that i'm just used to it i i mean i
don't really find it difficult to deal
with just put on more layers or turn on
a heater
loneliness that's an interesting one we
may come back to that one boredom
man with two kids
a full-time job
playing video games reading books doing
this youtube channel boredom is like not
even close to being on my radar so i
think it's gonna come down to loneliness
or being ignored
i'm a little bit of an introvert though
at times like i really enjoy my alone
time like i get a lot of stuff done kind
of goes hand in hand with the
non-boredom so i guess i would say being
ignored what are you most looking
forward to learning at hogwarts note i'm
allowed only six answer slots per
question if you don't like any answers
here click on none of these to vote on
the second half of the answer choices ah
okay i see what it means here so on this
particular question the way this quiz
works i guess they couldn't fit them all
into one so number one every area of
magic that i can apparition and
disapparition transfiguration flying on
a broomstick hexes and jinxes all about
magical creatures and how to befriend
care for them secrets about the castle
or none of these i mean this one's kind
of obvious here but i'm just going to
say every area of magic that i can and
on this one it says if i already vote in
the last one i put none of these here so
yeah i mean
it's kind of a cop-out answer a little
bit but yeah every answer or every every
answer every area of magic if you could
have any power which would you choose
the power to read minds that would be
incredible but heck no i don't want that
at all the power of invisibility
that one's leading so far power of
superhuman strength
nah power to speak to animals
that'd be kind of cool power to change
the past now you talk about powerful
that is insanely powerful but if i
started meddling with that i would be
too afraid that
it'd be like a butterfly effect
a flecked butterfly effect situation
where i would change one little thing
and then like
many years down the road something else
major happens that i would not want so i
don't think i would want that one at all
so i think it's gonna come down to
invisibility or change your appearance
at will
i'm gonna go change your appearance it
will because that's basically as good as
being invisible right i mean if you can
change your appearance at will you could
get into any building on the face of the
earth that you wanted to get into by
changing into the right person i would
think okay 16 here over halfway through
which of the following would you most
like to study here we go same situation
here only allowed six slots to answer
per question
okay area i would most like to study
centaurs goblins mer people ghosts
vampires werewolves or trolls
oh okay vampires no ghosts no goblins no
centaurs
yes werewolves i think would probably be
a close second but trolls no thank you
okay 18 one of your housemates has
cheated in a hogwarts exam oh i love
this one by using a self-spelling quill
now he has come top of the class in
charms beating you into second place
professor flitwick is suspicious of what
happened he draws you to one side after
his lesson and asks you whether or not
your classmate used a forbidden
will what do you
do
lie and say you don't know but hope that
somebody else tells professor flitwick
the truth nope that's not gonna be it
for me
tell professor flitwick that he ought to
ask your classmate and resolve to tell
your classmate that if he doesn't tell
the truth you will
three tell professor flitwick the truth
if your classmate is prepared to win by
cheating he deserves to be found out
also as you are both in the same house
any points he loses will be regained by
you for coming first in his place and
last you would not wait to be asked to
tell professor the truth if you knew
that somebody was using a forbidden
quill you would tell the teacher before
the exam started okay that's hermione
right there that is definitely the
hermione answer for me it's gonna be
number two number three i'm not gonna
lie like i i just that's not in my
nature that's not who i am i wouldn't
lie about it so i think if i was
actually confronted by the teacher and
the teacher said
whether or not your classmate used a
forbidden quill like if i would have to
be a hundred percent sure you guys are
going to call me a rat now like no you
rat retro no i would have to be a
hundred percent sure if i was absolutely
sure that they used a forbidden quill
and the teacher asked me
[Music]
oh man but what if it's like your good
friend though
okay now i'm second guessing this
now i'm really second guessing this
there was a boy meets world episode that
was something somewhere close to this
you guys remember that episode
oh and corey like he he didn't rat sean
out like he did not tell and he took the
punishment instead
oh man i'm really having a hard time
like
would i just go ahead and tell the truth
because
i think number two is probably the best
answer as a friend because
ask the classmate and then you go to the
classmate and say hey if you don't tell
the truth i'm gonna have to go forward
yeah i'm gonna do that one i'm gonna say
number two here all right number 19 you
and two friends need to cross a bridge
guarded by a river troll who insists on
fighting one of you before he will let
all of you pass okay do you number one
attempt to confuse the troll into
letting all three of you pass without
fighting two suggest drawing lots to
decide which of you will fight three
suggests that all three of you should
fight without telling the troll
or volunteer to fight
wow there are actually i think three
good answers here suggest drawing lots
is not something i would do attempt to
confuse the troll that obviously makes a
lot of sense if you can avoid fighting
in this situation that would be ideal or
suggest all three of you can fight it's
like okay let's not tell the troll let's
just take him out right here all of us
together by far the most reasonable is
to try and avoid the fight with the
troll at all cost number 20 which road
tempts you most the wide sunny grassy
lane
the narrow dark lantern lit alley the
twisting leaf strong paths through the
woods the cobbled street lined with
ancient buildings without a doubt for me
it's the cobbled street lined with
ancient buildings i love cobblestone
always have and i can just picture these
like massive buildings around me that
one without a doubt which nightmare
would frighten you most standing on top
of something very high and realizing
suddenly that there are no hand or foot
holes nor any barrier to stop you
falling
two an eye at the keyhole of the dark
windowless room in which you are locked
geez
waking up to find that neither of your
friends nor your family have any idea
who you are
last being forced to speak in such a
silly voice that hardly anyone can
understand you and everyone laughs you
okay i don't care about that at all i
think that would be hilarious standing
on top of something very high uh i mean
i'm not too afraid of heights that one
doesn't bother me the eye at the keyhole
that would certainly be frightening but
waking up to find out that neither of
your friends nor your family have any
idea who you are like dude that's
that's truly terrifying like if you
actually believed it i know it says
nightmare but if you you know how it is
in dreams you feel like it's real i
gotta go with that one late at night
walking alone down the street you hear a
peculiar cry that you believe to have a
magical source do you proceed with
caution keeping one hand on your
concealed wand and an eye out for any
disturbance two draw your wand and try
to discover the source of the noise
three draw your wand and stand your
ground four withdraw into the shadows to
await developments while mentally
reviewing the most appropriate defensive
and offensive spells should trouble
occur draw your want i definitely don't
think i would try to discover the source
of the noise i'm not just gonna stand
there either so that one's out withdraw
into the shadows no way like i don't
want to wait around for this thing i
think i would proceed with caution and
then just yeah keep an eye out that one
i think is pretty simple for me a muggle
confronts you and says that they are
sure you are a witch or wizard do you
ask what makes them think so agree and
ask whether they'd like a free sample of
a jinx
agree and walk away leaving them to
wonder whether you're bluffing tell them
that you're worried about their mental
health and offer to call a doctor
who asked them
okay
all right i gotta put myself
in this situation here okay i'm a wizard
and you're not supposed like part of the
rules being a wizard you're not supposed
to tell muggles right ask what makes
them think so agree and
ask whether they'd like a free sample of
jinx definitely not going to do that one
so it's between one and three here agree
and walk away leaving them to wonder
whether you're bluffing like i kind of
like that one
especially if it's somebody i don't know
very well i just think i would be like
of course i am and just keep walking ask
what makes them think so like that leads
to a whole nother
you know then this conversation is going
to drag out i think you get yourself
into trouble there so i'm just going to
go with this option all right so it
looks like all the rest of them are
these toss-ups and i'm just gonna say
these drive me crazy i do not like these
at all personally i don't see how they
could determine which house you're in or
like which trait i mean it's totally a
toss-up right like my answer to these
will change based on the day
that i'm answering it or how i'm
interpreting the question so i'm
caveating this before we see my final
result here i am caveating this by
saying that okay dawn or dusk well for
me i've always been a night owl and i
don't see that changing anytime soon so
i'm gonna say dusk moon or stars like
what about
moon or stars like do
i don't know stars
forest or river what about a river in a
forest you know what today i'm feeling
more foresty i'm gonna say forest black
or white like
what
what is this again this depends on the
day
that you're asking me like
when i think of black and white i think
of iphone colors like throughout the
years the the different iphones that
i've owned i feel like i always go back
and forth like sometimes i'll be like oh
man i really want the black iphone
right now i'm rocking a black iphone i'm
gonna go black heads or tails
i mean again it's just 50 50. like how
does this have anything whatsoever to do
with your house
uh today i'm gonna say tails left or
right uh i'm right-handed so let's say
right all right guys here we go the
moment of truth we are about to submit
the answers
i really have no idea like i feel like
it's probably going to be gryffindor
with a chance
of a ravenclaw so let's go ahead and
submit and see what the results show and
there it is you guys gryffindor with 89
wow not even close really ravenclaw
coming in second at 46 slytherin
actually in third at 40
a lot closer to ravenclaw than i
expected to be honest and then
hufflepuff down at the bottom 31
congratulations you have been sorted
into gryffindor the house of bravery and
chivalry you are amongst other
gryffindor such as harry potter
gryffindor so there you go that is the
house that i will be choosing
for hogwarts legacy i know i know it's
cliche but that's the one that uh came
out on top for me so let me know what
you guys get make sure you let me know
in the comments below also don't forget
to give this video a thumbs up so that
helps more people on youtube find it and
guys i want to thank you all so much for
watching the channel has been growing
like crazy lately i really really do
appreciate your support we're going to
do something big when we hit 10k subs as
always thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon